Speaker 1: Want to see what happens
when mental illness combines with
cult membership, combines with too
much time on people's hands? Well,
it's Kerry Lake supporters. Kerry Lake is
very rapidly heading towards what is likely,
but not yet guaranteed to be a loss in the
Arizona gubernatorial election. This is very
good for the residents of Arizona. Carrie Lake
is one of the worst people to run in this cycle,
right up there with Mastriano and Blake Masters
and Herschel Walker and a few others. It is,
of course, a situation that Carrie Lake and her
supporters have backed themselves into a corner
around because they were insisting it's rigged,
there will be fraud. And there if if there is not
fraud, I will win. I will win. I will win. And
even as recently as I think it was yesterday,
Carrie Lake was saying, I'm going to win.
It doesn't really look like Carrie Lake is
going to win. And so her supporters showed
up in Maricopa County and had other ballot
counting centers. And they are mixing religion
with mental illness, with cult membership, with
having too much time on their hands. Here is one
clip in which they are demanding that the military
step in and just do a new election. I guess this
election was fake. They want a real election by
which they mean one in which Carrie Lake wins.
Speaker 3: But it will be done on earth as it
is in heaven. Give us the state.
Speaker 4: I want all of you to
say a prayer right now. We, the people are
requesting the military step in and redo.
Speaker 3: Our election.
Speaker 1: Request. Denied, sir, as.
Speaker 4: Fake and false, its full. Our
government is full of corrupt people. Oh.
Speaker 3: Oh, oh.
Speaker 1:
Yeah. There were a bunch of these
people out. Here's one person with
a megaphone who was shouting
common shadow government tropes
where wealthy men often they just happen
to be Jewish. Men are actually in control
of that.
Unidentified: We are paying,
by all accounts are Rockefeller, Krakoff.
Speaker 1: Wright, Rockefeller,
Rothschild and JPMorgan are
responsible for this evil.
Yep. Then there is another Kerry Lake supporter
calling for a new election. And remember,
they are serious folks. The U.S. is now seen
as the joke where when your candidate loses,
you say we need a new election. And Trump
even called for it. He actually called for
a new electron, not a new election.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
Speaker 5: I believe at this point, we
need to just have a new election at this.
Speaker 1: Point now that it's pretty damn clear
Kerry Lake is going to lose. Now, we are actually
ready to say we need a totally new election.
Speaker 5: And we need to do paper ballots
and we need to do it all in one day and
be done with it. We can't expect it's an
absurd notion to sit here and play this
charade and act like after this counting
that we won't have tainted results either way.
Speaker 1: What he means is it's hard to believe
Kerry will win after the election is over.
Speaker 5: So we should just really redo
this entire election.
Speaker 1: Yep. Do it
all over again. And then certainly an idea
that Trump likes. And then another. Another
point. They were chanting Count the legal
votes. This is another trope. Well, yeah,
sure, there's lots of votes to count, but you're
counting illegal votes only. Count the legal ones.
Speaker 3: Count the legal votes. Count legal
no legal vote. Count the legal votes count
the legal votes count. The legal will count.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, you know this routine
now, it's the same routine every election.
It's the that it's just that it's if we lost,
it was rigged, stolen. There were ballot dumps. We
need a new election. It was all fake, fake, fake,
rigged but rigged. They say nothing in the races
that they won. They say nothing in those races.
Tim Scott's race in South Carolina, have you heard
a peep out of them about that one? Of course not.
Brian Kemp in Georgia, they're
not saying or they're not saying
the Herschel Walker. Oh, very much rigged.
Brian Kemp. Stacey Abrams, same ballots.
Stacey Abrams lost genuinely. Brian Kemp won
genuinely. That's really the result. They say,
oh, no, no, no, no, that one's real.
That one's very real. The U.S. is a joke
where we win. It's fair if we lose. It was
rigged. According to these very same people.